when you are talking about your
experience of looking at at robots it
reminds me of how I for many years have
been looking at plants
because the plant behavior and actually
this is the example maybe we'll just try
it out it may not work this is an
example I was thinking of recently
because I was reading back on the work
of Mark Jaffe who did this research with
P10 rules I'm sure he did many other
plant studies but this is the one I was
reading about and I'm hoping this
analogy I'll just set it up I'm hoping
that this analogy will be something that
we can keep coming back to as we move
forward because
you know as we shake up our intuitions
and get confused and then our in we come
back to our intuitions and say no that
just can't be I think this analogy might
might be helpful but what kind of plant
was he working on uh P tendrils so p a p
plant has these tendrils you can you can
picture them they they
um
coil
so
I don't I don't know what year this
research was done I'm I'm guessing in
the 80s but you know some but Pete
Andrews have been around long before
that yes of course
doing the research on the humans but
that's another thing yeah right
P tendrils as a system
generally there are a few more things
they can do but generally they can
behave in two ways they can grow in a
straight line slowly
or they can grow in this coil form more
quickly
and what happens is when they are
growing in a straight Manner and they
encounter a branch or a pole or
something else that it can wrap itself
around to gain more stability when it
senses a branch there that gives it the
cue to start growing at a more rapid
pace and to start coiling instead of
growing straight
so it has these two behaviors as a
system it's capable of growing straight
and it's capable of coiling
one interesting thing actually I'll just
add this it's not totally relevant but
one interesting thing is
um Mark jaffe's work so he um cut a P10
drill he was curious to see if it could
do this on its own separate from the
rest of the plant so he cut a pitendril
off the plants if you keep it in a moist
warm environment it will continue to to
behave in these ways so it will continue
to coil if he he noticed that if he
touched one end of it if he rubbed one
side of it that gave it enough of a cue
that it would start to coil and then he
noticed that it needed light to perform
this action so in the dark when he
rubbed the the edge of the tendril it
did not coil
um in the light it would and then he
recognized this further fact which was
that the P tendril that he rubbed in the
dark that was still straight if he
brought it out into the light and this
could be hours later it would start to
coil
it has a primitive form of memory where
it's it's has the sensation and then it
holds on to that information and as soon
as there's light it acts on that but
also in the kind of distributed
intelligence because you can separate it
from the main
right in the main part right like if you
chop off a human arm it's not gonna
right keep growing even if you keep it
in a moist warm environment it's not
going to reach out for the cup of coffee
when you come in with Starbucks maybe
maybe in the correct environment maybe
we just haven't found the environment
but anyway that's pretty amazing so
that's the separate fact but anyway so
so if you just use the analogy of a p
tendril and if you imagine which is
something I like to do a lot if you
imagine
um this plant has some kind of conscious
experience of course it doesn't have
complex thought it doesn't have anything
like a human experience but if it were
possible for a plant to have some felt
experience you can imagine that when it
comes into contact with a branch and
starts to coil that that feeling could
be one of deciding to do that or that it
feels good to do that or kind of wanting
I mean it's that's too complex that's
that's anthropomorphizing but there's a
way in which you could imagine this P
tendril under those circumstances
suddenly wants to start coiling so
you're saying you try to meditate potato
what it's like to be a p tendril a plant
like that's what's required here
it's like you have to empathize with a
plant or with another organism that's
not human yeah and you don't actually
need that for this analogy that of the
larger analogy that I'm getting at but I
think that's an interesting piece to
keep in mind that you could imagine that
in nature if there's a conscious
experience associated with a p tendril
that at that moment what that feels like
is
a want to start moving in a different
way so you you want to imagine that
without anthropomorphizing so without
projecting The Human Experience but
rather sort of humbling yourself that
we're just another plant with more
complexity yes like trying to see where
exactly so that yeah that's where I'm
going with this sure so and and when you
start making that connection you can see
where there are a few points at which
there's room for an illusion to come in
for our own feelings of will so when we
move from the P tendril to human
decision making obviously human decision
making human brains are many many many
times more complex than whatever is
going on in a p tendril I mean it is the
brain is actually the most complex thing
we know of in the universe thus far
so there is the genes that help develop
the brain into any particular brain into
what it is they're all the inputs
they're they're countless factors that
we could never I mean it may as well be
an infinite number of factors and then
in that particular moment whatever the
inputs are to a brain the brain is
capable of almost an infinite number of
outputs right so if you if I walked in
here this morning and you said um would
you like water or tea
um and that's you know simple decision
for me passive aggressive way of telling
me I should have offered
some tea but yes go on no I wanted water
okay all right you I actually asked for
water okay all right and you didn't have
any free will anyway so it doesn't
matter I don't I don't hope you're
responsible for any of it exactly I was
just running an algorithm so
feministically you could you give me
this decision right to make water or tea
go back to the pizza Central for a
second a p tendril is capable of growing
in a straight line slowly or in a coil
quickly
um my brain is capable of all kinds of
responses to that question even though
you've given me you know two options you
could offer me water or tea and I could
just run out of the room screaming if I
wanted to right happens to me all the
time never mind I don't want to do this
yes the fact that the brain is capable
that there's so many inputs and then the
brain is capable of so many outputs as a
system what it's hard for us to get our
minds around is that it may not be
capable of any
behavior in every moment in time so as a
system it's capable of doing all kinds
of
things
and the points I'm making is that
if we could see all of the factors
leading up to the moment where I chose
water or where I ran screaming from the
room
um we could in fact see that there's
there was no other Behavior I was going
to or could have exhibited in that
moment in the same way that when the P
tendril hits the branch it starts
coiling there's a parallel which is very
interesting in robotics with with fish
and water so you could see they've
experienced like dead fish and they keep
swimming so
the fish is capable of all kinds of
complicated movements as a system but
in any one moment the river the full
complexity of the River defines the
actual movement of the fish that's
sufficient well and I I should also I
mean this brings up another point which
is that there is a difference between
voluntary and involuntary Behavior so of
course we have reflexes and it is a
different there's different brain
processing in action when I make a
decision about water or tea then there
is you know if my behavior is forced
from the outside or if I have a brain
tumor that's causing me to make certain
decisions or feel certain feelings and
so
um the point is that at bottom it's all
brain processing and behavior but the
reason why certain actions feel Wilt
there's a good reason why it feels that
way
and it's to distinguish our own
self-generated behavior based on
thinking and you know possibly weighing
the different results of different
things I already had caffeine today I
don't want more you know they're all
these
um processes things that we can point to
and things that we can't things I'm
affected by at a subconscious level
um
and that is very different from an
unwilled action or reflex or something
like that and so some people I can
imagine I haven't used the P tendril
example but I can imagine they wouldn't
like that because the p tendril
um sounds more to them like a reflex and
that doesn't address the question of a
much more complex
decision-making process but I think at
bottom
um that is that is what it is and that's
really where the illusion of Free Will
and the illusion of self which I think
is they're kind of two sides of the same
coin come from so even when we
intellectually understand
that everything we're feeling everything
we're doing is is based on our brain
processing and brain Behavior if you're
a physicalist you you've bought into
that
um even when you intellectually
understand that we and I could include
myself in this we still have this
feeling that there's something that
stands outside of the brain processing
that can intervene and that's the
illusion